mais pouvoir d'achat et qui est aussi un
sujet récurrent dans le programme des
candidats aux élections législatives
premier tour le 12 juin un deuxième tour
est fixé au 19 juin tv 78 vous aide à y
voir plus clair sur ce scrutin et ses
enjeux dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines aujourd'hui
nous nous intéressons à la 8e
circonscription est avec mathilde franco
bonjour mathilde de la rédaction de tv
78 déjà où se situe ce territoire et et
quelles communes composent cette
huitième circonscription alors grégory
cette huitième circonscription elle est
située au nord du département en vallée
de seine centré autour de la ville de
mantes la jolie elle regroupe 22
communes et représente 116000 yvelinois
environ avec des grandes villes comme
l'hymne et magnanville ou encore mantes
la ville et des petits villages comme
drocourt follainville dennemont ou
mental et le bois d'ailleurs en fonction
des zones géographiques on ne vote pas
de la même manière si à la
présidentielle les villes ont largement
donné leurs voix au candidat de la
france insoumise jean luc mélenchon les
villages ont préféré miser sur le
rassemblement national avec marine le
pen il ya donc une véritable fracture
une incompréhension entre villes et
campagnes dans la 8e circonscription et
qui est aujourd'hui le député à la tête
de cette circonscription qui est député
sortant alors c'est michel vial et vial
et pardon l'ancien maire de mantes la
jolie entre 2005 et 2010 cette qui
dirige cette huitième circonscription
lorsqu'il se présente il est devancé par
la candidate de la république en marche
khadija mounim au premier tour mais elle
crée la surprise au second tour et
devient finalement députés c'est alors
le seul membre des républicains sur tout
le département a accédé à l'assemblée
nationale toutes les autres
circonscriptions ont été gagnées par la
majorité présidentielle
lrm modem ce renversement de tendance
est due en partie à la mobilisation de
pierre bédier le président du
département pour sa candidature alors
est-ce que le soutien de pierre bédier
va encore lui servir dans quelques
semaines ce n'est pas si sûr il a
quelques jours lors de la municipale
partielle de mantes la jolie le candidat
investi par le président du département
al le mont perdu face à raphaël cogné le
maire l'ancien maire démissionnaire
poussé vers la sortie d'ailleurs
mathilde dans les candidats présents
face à michel vialay y aura notamment un
soutien de raphaël connu effectivement
grégory il s'agit des devises hervieu
ancienne adjointe chargée de la
transition écologique à la mairie de
mantes la jolie elle a toujours soutenu
raphaël cogner c'est d'ailleurs elle qui
l'a poussé à se représenter aujourd'hui
elle et sa première adjointe aux
affaires générales elle a donc été
investi par la majorité présidentielle
pour les législatives et sa candidature
ne fait pas l'unanimité déjà dans le
camp de pierre bédier on voit sa
nomination comme une déclaration de
guerre puis son investiture n'est pas
très bien vu non plus par certains
militants 40 et 1017 edwige hervieux
avait décidé de faire campagne pour
michel vial et et en 2020 la candidate a
pris sa carte chez les républicains mais
dans cette bataille des législatives
celui qui pourrait faire sa place et le
candidat du rassemblement national et
oui l'ancien maire de mantes la ville
cyril note pourrait tirer son épingle du
jeu professeur d'histoire géographie il
adhère au front national en 2010 il peut
compter sur les voix des habitants des
petits villages comme à follainville et
guîtres en cours ou marine le pen est
arrivé en tête au second tour de la
présidentielle
cependant les voies pour l'extrême
droite pourraient se partager avec la
candidature reconquête annecy car le qui
sont les autres candidats pour la gauche
il s'agit de benjamin lucas il
représentera la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et solidaire alias la nuque
coordinateur du mouvement générations
point s il est également conseiller
régional des eaux et des eaux de france
bardot il fait partie des candidats
parachutés pour être dans les yvelines
et ce dernier croit à la victoire de la
gauche aux législatives et souhaite que
jean luc mélenchon devienne premier
ministre enfin parmi les autres
candidats bernard kossoko sans étiquette
politique
thierry gonot pour lutte ouvrière
jacques lefebvre pour le parti ouvrier
indépendant démocratique
françois blaise pour le parti
animalistes jean préau pour l'union des
démocrates musulmans et mélanie bekono
pour les patriotes l'on rappelle les
dates un les 12 et 19 juin pour ces
élections législatives merci matile pour
ce pont sur la 8e circonscription des
yvelines